Phoebe you hang out with older members
of family hmm man I can find them this
event cycle women of the world event
that I'd like gatecrash broken into you
climb through a window into whatever it
was everyone was being introduced and
Camilla parker-bowles was approaching me
with one of those like assistance behind
her who like tells her who coming
towards me and she was so she was like
giving her ear to the VIN game
[Applause]
and then like a TV camera was like
another this is gonna go wrong
I'm writer and I write TV shows and I'm
at sea and I just thought yeah women
into it
I'm writing a show at the moment about a
female assassin and a female mi5 agent
and they're kind of chasing each other
around the world and she was like oh
lovely you had a lot of girl-on-girl
action chemistry between the two of you
between Jericho replaced villanelle and
yourself and did you know that was gonna
be there or does it develop is that just
good acting what's the story you know
all those three things you're saying did
you know to develop and is a good acting
I think it's all three things I just say
I'm so impressed you were listening to
what I was thinking I'm hardly listening
to myself Wow and so those three points
it's like when I first met Jody and we
had our first kind of chemistry read
together I knew that we had good
chemistry I could just tell because it
was actually speaking about listening it
was I could it was the way that we were
listening together and the way that I
could hear and I it's only so much I
could hear I could feel how she was
receiving anything that I was moving
giving to her and that she would react
and I I do think chemistry in some ways
between actors is about listening so I
think it's to have that skill as well
sorry oh yeah you your one your main
accent is amazing but then you go off
and do the different languages and
things like was that something I mean
obviously we'd heard you do kind of
English act yes but was that something
you knew you could do I was a kid were
you good have accents I've always like
imitated
adverts and stuff with my dad but I was
the same as I'm like in the audition it
was like you know she she
many languages and I was like of course
why and then like never thinking that I
was like you know it would happen and
then as each episode came through I was
like Oh Russian German like they all
yeah they kept going Wow yeah favorite
one to do in the show I really enjoyed
doing the Italian purely because that
was the one they found easiest to do
French is really hard and Daniel mean
you've done accents in lots of films but
there was a couple of words burning an
American that you still struggle with
well I know knots like not as much time
because I've had but I remember the
first one of the first things I did as
in American accent like the word
girlfriend was very hard and the word
murderer and I had to say I was playing
a person who was accused of murdering
his girlfriend so like every time I came
up against a black girlfriend no but
like doing but that's bits accidents is
one but like speaking languages I've had
to do I have to say one line of French
once and it was the most stressful all
right for every take I forgot Lopez this
a lot of outtakes to me going line
please anyone help it's like it's quite
nerve-wracking I love your Russian in it
cuz it's so badass thank you
and I was doing in a bit lately people
come up to me and I'm just like no I'm
not in the mood
I've created this like Russian II
Russian persona
[Music]
and then people come up and they go oh
hi you rebel Wilson and I go no no what
do you want ally and I just trying to
try to channel you is it like livestock
you know there there are chickens in my
neighbor's yard and so I go over there
and visit them regularly um no I know I
live right in Los Angeles I don't live
on a place with a lot of land or
anything like that so it's um very City
living well somebody's about to get you
put you posted this this video of you
visiting the chickens I know it was so
weird is is that lockdown or wine that
it was I don't know how many weeks deep
into Cove it but I if I made that little
video and then was so absurd but also
really really you know capturing a
moment in in in lockdown because I each
clearly I'm not paying attention to
anything that I'm wearing and I'm trying
to mimic the sound of other birds in my
neighborhood and speak to them but yes
there's a full glass of wine in my head
yeah the whole thing that villanelle
because she is this is quite an extreme
character presumably you get extreme
reactions from fans and things when you
when you meet people in the street yeah
I mean a lot of people just look at me
and think is it her but I had one
recently that was really strange someone
asked me and for Afro to graph and I was
like yeah sure and was posing for a
photograph and then she quietly just
whispered in my ear will you strangle me
I'm a bother sisters with me at the time
and she was like no we will not Killa
gave such such such a huge hit and we
saw the famous scene there on the the
bus that must have been like doing the
fight scenes hard anyway but trying to
choreograph the fight scene on a bus
must be extra complicated yes we were
shooting that around around Notting Hill
I think and we were just on this very
very very slow loop that goes around and
we're shooting on on a live bus which is
actually quite quite great it's
challenging a lot of ways because also
you have all your crew members with
cameras and sound equipment moving along
with you and there was a bit of a fight
sequence there so it was fun very fun it
was it was it a fever no car tape okay
occasionally for hiding backstage there
are some japes with actors you know sure
sure sure you know you know but keep the
other actors kind of and entertained at
when it's a really long run and I'm
really sorry mum that I'm telling the
story and there was one I was doing hay
fever and was a three-month run and
there was one moment it's one moment on
the stage where I was offstage with this
other actor Sam and one of the other
actors played one of the Karen's played
by Freddy Fox would storm across the
stage open this door and we'd be
standing behind the door you know master
on the audience and he had to go and
then he'd slam the door and run back
onto the stage and so we always used to
do something kind of quirky behind the
door to make him laugh and every night
we started off by doing a little like oh
like with kissing or like oh we put a
funny hat on Sam but it was three months
long this run we had to hug the game
every night goodnight until we started
getting the stage management involved
and there were massive like hot dog
costumes and
I'm outside to come in - every time
straight even open the door he'd be like
really cause I didn't even like change
really quickly and then run on for sage
and that others cast members could see
it and it was building and building
really running out of ideas and it's
like a week left and we were exhausting
ourselves and then suddenly it was
getting to the last night we were like
we have to have a big finish like what
are we gonna do for Freddy and neither
of us could think of anything and
suddenly we get the matinee and we've
done this kind of wild kinda like
spangly glittery thing and then on the
final book III have nothing and we were
like we have to do something we have to
do something we could hear Freddy coming
across the stage and we're like we
haven't thought of anything perfect
pink skirt or do they run the story is
gonna be great the London's data Olivia
Colman Lindsey Duncan giving rally all
going yeah too far
[Applause]
[Music]
you